good morning believe nation today's
message is love what you do now over to
David Beckham I've always been driven
you know even a young age all I ever
wanted to do was become a footballer or
a soccer star and that was my only
ambition you know I know it's different
these days with kids you know there's
obviously this Fame this fortune and it
might be easy for me to say that because
obviously I've done I've done very well
out of the game but you know I'd still
be playing this game even if I wasn't
being paid for it no that doesn't want
to be paid for it I still would be
playing for paying playing this this
school so what do you think I think it's
a great message and I love that David
said it's easy for me to sit here and
say this I think you can love what you
do but what you do might not always be
what you love they can be two separate
things for example I don't want to talk
about me for more than 10 seconds but
I've wanted to play piano my whole life
considered going to Juilliard and at one
point I realized I'm good I'm not that
good and me pursuing what I love isn't
gonna feed my family isn't going to take
care of my ambitions so I do something
else
but in my spare time I play piano
sometimes I'll go to a hotel and sit at
some piano in a bar and sometimes people
give me money and it's amazing but I am
NOT gonna have that as my career but I
think you can keep that passion you can
keep it ignited and it might not
necessarily be part of your larger
career plan but you can have a spinoff I
think you need to have the passion to
keep going and what you're doing like
you drove here from Cleveland you've
been up since I don't know how long 19
hours 19 hours to come and do this you
know I look forward to Wednesday which
is video day
it drives me
it's one of the best days of the week
for me being an entrepreneur so hard
it's so hard and if you look at you know
in any profession I guess gonna be so
hard the people who've risen to the top
of the people who truly enjoy the work
that they're doing if I stopped loving
making videos I would stop making videos
and move on to do something else that I
love and I think entrepreneurs will
often get trapped in that they maybe
love it at the start but stop loving it
and then it prevents them from doing
something greater the thing that gets
you through the darkness they're like
this is just so crazy that you have to
love what you're doing when my first
presentation I did at a YMCA only three
people showed up it was a free thing and
I thought I'm never gonna make money off
of this like if through people show up
for a free thing how am I ever gonna
turn us into a business but it just I
loved it like it made me come alive I
figured even I got to go get jobs to
support this I had to figure out a way
to keep doing it and it evolved into
what is now a YouTube channel never
thought you know X number of years ago
that I'm gonna be YouTube channel with
hundreds of thousand subscribers it just
came from following that love and
passion that I have so I hope people
watching are doing the same thing not
just opening up like ink magazine and
saying hey the 50 hottest companies to
start but actually doing something that
you are madly in love with so once again
your point was way better than anything
I formulated and the other thing that
got me thinking while you were speaking
is perseverance you have been so
persistent you've persevered and not
giving up and again loving what you do
usually means you're not gonna give up
as quickly as someone who doesn't yeah
you will you will give up if you don't
love what you're doing you'll give up as
soon as it gets super hard you'll give
up so the question of the day today is
for those of you that have worked for
CEOs and major companies before pursuing
your independent dream did they love
what they did interesting leave it in
the comments below we'll join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
we go